bonjour je suis tel c'est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du
soulier
[Musique]
dans histoire de souliers nous allons
explorer l'univers de la chaussure
féminine de l'escarpin à la ballerine en
passant par la chaussure compenser les
bottines les bottes les mary jane
les cuissardes et toutes les autres
mais comme disait bette midler donné une
fille des chaussures correct et elle
peut conquérir le monde
dans histoire de souligner je vous dirai
tout sur cette arme de destruction et de
séduction massive les femmes et leurs
chaussures où la relation la plus
fusionnel qui soit avec un accessoire
votre vie ne sera vue et car la quête du
graal trouver la chaussure parfait on
change ou sans son histoire et les
infinies possibilités offertes à nos
gens aujourd'hui dans histoire de
souliers vous découvrirez la cuissarde
comment cette chaussure à la réputation
si particulière at-elle crié son chemin
à travers l'histoire avec quoi vaut-il
mieux porter la cuissarde retrouver nos
professionnels de la mode pour toutes
les explications avec toujours plus
d'archivés et d'expérience à l'appui
vous découvrirez ensuite les conseils
look et shopping de nos professionnels
qui vous révéleront les tendances du
moment
vous saurez ce qui est totalement in et
ce quitte à ne pas faire vous
retrouverez en temps notre rubrique des
modèles les plus extravagants de la
haute couture et du design mais tout
d'abord vous avez peut-être un petit mot
à nous dire sur cette chaussure si
particulière
[Musique]
paris nous avons mené notre petite
enquête dans la capitale pour savoir
comment vous abordiez la cuissarde quels
conseils mesdames
sarde moi je trouve que c'est bon c'est
joli c'est sexy c'est
moi je trouve ça sympa du bien oui bon
sens
[Musique]
tous
salut 5e de séduction la crise tarde
n'importe quelle chaussure mai
voilà ça c'est quand même moi je sais
que je mets ça quand j'ai envie d'être
sexy avant la mini jupe et autant mettre
un collant opaque quelque chose d'un peu
plus loin
ça reste classe quand même c'est le
travail de sape et régulier
[Musique]
la cuissarde est une chaussure
relativement récente
même si elle est directement inspirée de
la bottine et du monde cavaliers
généralement associée à une petite robe
moulante dans un pur esprit seventies
elle peut être portée avec plus de
mesure et par tout les sabres puis ce
fut la cuissarde est un modèle phare de
ces dernières saisons découvrons
ensemble comment cette chaussure est né
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la cuissarde vous évoque
beaucoup de choses
j'adore les cuisses away d'abord les
plus hard plate avec un short c'est
génial alors évidemment dans
l'imaginaire populaire likely salariés
plus tôt pour savoir quand premier en
plus de mauvaise vie ce truc que quand
on ne la joue pas en talons aiguilles de
12 cm est la cuisse a peut être hyper
sympa abily une tenue être assez sobre
voilà la cuissarde c'est c'est aussi les
bases des mousquetaires qui re monter
très haut
d'artagnan l'installation est
d'inspiration d'ateliers où l'amour non
mais c'est vrai la tuta voilà tout à
fait raison c'est vrai que dans nos
têtes ça évoque un côté ultra sexy et
même un peu outrageux mais en fait ça ne
l'est pas voilà quand c'est bien la
corde et la cuissarde est revenue
vraiment à la mode ça ne l'était pas du
tout ça n'a jamais été même je pense et
là la salle des vraiment donc la
cuissarde est encore à la mode
oui la cuissarde cet hiver ne sera plus
autant à la mode que l'hiver dernier où
que l'hiver encore précédent mais
vraiment plates bien accorder plutôt
sobre la cuissarde étant indispensable
[Musique]
et la cuissarde est très difficile à
porter donc pour moi elle est réservée à
une minorité de femmes voilà parce que
tout le monde n'a pas dé longues jambes
tout le monde n'a pas des gens fine
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
clients qui qui fantasme sur la
cuissarde mais malheureusement tout le
monde ne pourra pas la porte et ça c'est
ma grande préoccupation de ne pas tasser
du sexy au vulgaire
déjà on choisit une cuissardes selon sa
morphologie je le répète mais c'est très
important donc d'avoir une hauteur aussi
que bien approprié à sa jambe et il faut
l'accessoiriser avec des vêtements mais
très très sobre sans vulgarité sans
bling-bling sens tu rassembles il faut
être
il faut avoir une jolie cuissardes mais
avec 1
un des accessoires très soft la
cuissarde par définition c'est au-dessus
du genou mais dans des poteries hyper
souple et je pense que il ne faut plus
avoir la cuissarde hyper serré non il
faut que qu'elle est quand même il faut
que la jambe est quand même un peu
d'aisance voiliers de façon à ce que
cela ne fasse pas ridicule et surtout
très vive hier
[Musique]
les experts s'accordent à dire que la
botte et la sandale sont les chaussures
les plus anciennes toutes deux inventé
sensiblement au même moment
elle répondait chacune a des besoins
différents l'une devait s'adapter au sol
sablonneux et l'autre protéger du froid
cependant ce ne sont pas des sandales
que l'on a retrouvée sur les peintures
rupestres les plus anciennes mais bien
des bottes en fourrure et impôts de la
renaissance à la révolution
seuls les hommes portaient des
cuissardes elle avait pour but de
protéger le pantalon des frottements
contre la selle de cheval
[Musique]
et quand les hommes ne montait pas à
cheval
il était d'usagé de rabattre le haut de
la cuissarde sur le genou on parle alors
de porc à la mousquetaires seules
certaines graines comme catherine de
russie
porter des cuissards depuis lors de la
révolution industrielle les bottes
deviennent plus accessibles et
représente le symbole de l'égalité entre
les sexes mais surtout les classes
sociales
[Musique]
mais c'est réellement à la fin des
années 1960 que les cuissardes explose
après avoir été porté de façon marginale
quelques hivers auparavant la cuissarde
devient alors la chaussure sexy par
excellence elle habille les icônes
glamour tels que brigitte bardot et même
les super héroïne tels que barbarella
[Musique]
alors malheureusement lectrices à est
réservé à une petite poignée de femmes
par contre moi j'adore donc on vendre
dans une salle dans une fille ça et tout
de suite on sent que la fille si elle
est libérée elle est confiante
tout le monde regarde il y a des cuisses
a qui sont très décorés et côté oeuvre
donc comme quelqu'un qui travaille dans
cette semaine c'est c'est des vrais
chef-d'oeuvre alors le côté borderline
de la crise a alors un vrai dire je
porte beaucoup de cuissards mais
énormément et j'ai très peu de problèmes
j'adore cette ambiguïté dans le produit
donc en fait comment ce que je l' ai
vite j'ai une visage naturel et j'ai eu
un comportement qui est indigne
par contre de jouer avec cette ambiguïté
ça m'amuse profondément alors
morphologiquement une cuisse art qui est
le plus proche à son cor et cri
ressemble le plus à son son deuxième
peau c'est le mode à la prendre dans mes
rêves les crises art que je recherche
toujours c'est presque comme une pro
talons ou une une colle en sait quelque
chose qui suivent la morphologie de la
femme etc dans des tissus donc on
utilise surtout des cuirs strache donc
quelque chose qu'il donnerait vraiment
cette côte est est lancé et qui met la
femme en valeur
la cuissarde nous évoque alors la
cuissarde à régler une réputation
attention très spécial attention aux
fautes de goût parce que tout de suite
sap est extrêmement mal interprété la
cuissarde je pense que c'est un fantasme
d'homme parce que à la fois c'est
extrêmement haut c'est compensé sa prime
le genou donc c'est peut-être parce
qu'il ya de plus on va dire féminin mais
lorsque c'est bien porté sur une jambe
assez fine avec vraiment une jupe qui
soit juste à la bonne hauteur
c'est extrêmement beau c'est magnifique
et puis surtout au niveau de la
silhouette
je pense que lorsque sa épouse vraiment
la forme de la jambe y a rien de plus
beau que ça donc la cuissarde
l'attention apportée avec avec avec
modération
c'est vrai que la cuissarde à la fois
elle a un côté très habillée avec la
plate forme et avec un talon mais on en
vend beaucoup beaucoup plus plate
et donc là c'est vrai que ça devient un
modèle qui peut être à la fois habile
passe partout parfois avec un esprit un
petit peu cavalier parce que souvent ce
qu'on a l'habitude de faire de faire une
tige qui soit réellement qu'au dessus du
genou avec la possibilité d'avoir un
revers donc soit un revers dans la
matière différents donc le dain pour la
cuissarde c'est quelque chose qu'on
privilégie plutôt que le cuir ça reste
quand même plus facile à porter et donc
ce qu'on fait c'est que la cuissarde
lorsqu'elle contre un petit peu au fond
on décide de faire le revers ont fait on
essaie de travailler la doublure en cuir
avec un bal agneaux avec un modèle
matière pour vraiment la mettre en
valeur
et voilà donc il ya ces deux types de
puits sarlat je pense que nous en terme
de roman tu aujourd'hui ce qu'on vend
beaucoup plus est le plat rapport aux
mais bon si jamais on voit pas le haut
on vendra jamais plaints parce que la
cuissarde est une pièce tendance la
cuissarde je pense que c'est vraiment
pas un article on porte tous les jours
sauf bien sûr en plate on en avait un
petit peu moins depuis quelques saisons
mais
je pense que ça va revenir puisque
finalement on est aujourd'hui dans une
mode
j'ai passé la crise ou pas mais quand
même un peu plus discrète
on est sur des choses on revient
vraiment à des valeurs sûres et c'est
vrai que la cuissarde canton la voix
haute
bon bah ça a un côté un petit peu plus
ostentatoire alors que finalement
aujourd'hui la mode se veut un petit peu
plus simple donc je pense que avec le
retour de la croissance et vacher sûr
qu'on verra beaucoup plus de les
fameuses rend beaucoup plus porter des
choses ben voilà on se mouille un peu
plus on a bien la cuissarde évoque bien
plus souvent icône glamour que les trois
mousquetaires et pourtant ces deux
symboles font partie de l'histoire de la
course
cette box qui monte au dessus du genou a
une connotation particulièrement sexy
elle représente la libération des moeurs
des années 70 et bien nombre de jeunes
gens ont découvert la somme unités grâce
au cuissard de brive et sur sa harley ou
encore de barbarella il faut inspirer
par la cuissarde voilà la cuissarde
c'est effectivement un travail qui est
extrêmement intéressant à réaliser ça
mais quand même le corps de la femme en
exergue etc c'est très amusant à faire
petite anecdote on en a réalisé une
dernièrement pour une une cantatrice
pour un de ses opéras et donc elle va
elle porte actuellement nos cuissardes
qui sont réalisés pour son costume de
cléopâtre skin cléopâtre moderne c'est
cécilia bartoli et donc c'était
extrêmement intéressant à faire la
cuissarde est un type de chaussures
assez peu prisé des créateurs de haute
couture des designers qui lui préfèrent
généralement la botte
toutefois et surtout dans les
collections hivernales il faut bien
avouer qu'en tant que chaussure la plus
grande elle recouvre une partie
conséquente du corps et infra lors des
possibilités de création hors du commun
c'est pourquoi on constate que cette
chaussure est souvent considéré comme
une pièce de vêtement à part entière
alexander mcqueen joue ici avec la
notion de surface de la cuissarde il
présente à travers ses habituels clin
d'oeil au style baroque un modèle à
sangles au talon travailler en métal
doré et dans un esprit différent ce
modèle un jour et selon un quadrillage à
la 7 est doté d'un talon transparent
chez l'yonne taminiaux nous retrouvons
un modèle à patins et sans talons très
travaillé et incrusté de strass
le tout aurait d'ailleurs plus l'alluré
d'un vêtement
car la chaussure fait ici partie
intégrante de la tenue en continuité
avec la robe
dans le même esprit chanel s'inspire des
chaussures historique de la conception
de cette puissance de seconde peau à
boucle et alan incrusté de strass
[Musique]
parmi les cuissardes de la maison dior
on vous trouve essentiellement des
modèles jouant avec le contraste des
cuirs traditionnelles associées à des
boucles un de nos créateurs phares en
france
christian louboutin à lille esthétique à
l'utile avec cette cuissardes équipés de
poche latérale de porte cartes de porter
ce stylo et bien sûr d'un emplacement
pour rouge à lèvres presque plus besoin
de sacs à main dans une inspiration
militaire pour des modèles voisin du
butin appose des rangées de boutons
parfois même des clous il est aussi à
l'origine de ce modèle en python ou se
chevauchent le jaune vif et une teinte
plus neutre
par ailleurs la marque sergio rossi joue
avec les matières telles qu'un imprimé
d'inspiration ethnique ou encore simule
la présence d'une marie jeanne blanche
par dessus une puis sarde en velours
noir
[Musique]
dans une perspective tout en sobriété
mais original
on retrouve chez manolo blahnik un
modèle à la bordure à jour et façon
dentelle
[Musique]
enfin rachel de claire propose des
cuissardes fait l'empiècement de
couleurs différentes pour des modèles
très colorés pour une allure qui n'est
parfois pas sans rappeler l'univers des
super-héros ou encore des comptes noté
[Musique]
mon conseil du jour sur la cuissarde la
cuissarde c'est une chaussure que
j'affectionne particulièrement parce qu
elle court bien la jambe
elle couvre le genou on a chaud l'hiver
on est bien dedans ça en produire un peu
douillet voilà mais par contre la
cuissarde je la conseille plutôt plates
ou avec un tout petit talon pour éviter
l'effet est un peu vulgaire un peu
outrageux de la cuissardes à talon et je
la saucisse ou avec un jean slim que je
rentre dans ma cuisse hard soit avec une
petite jupe ou un petit short voilà par
exemple un petit short en cuir avec une
cuissardes hyper sobre noir ou une
pistarde un peu moutarde avec des
collants noirs ou alors un short en jean
ou un slim noir bons conseils shopping
sur la cuissarde c'est d'avoir un une
silhouette très avantageuse pour la
porter et ne pas rentrer dans la dent
les lourdeurs des accessoires la
cuissarde est un modèle vraiment sexy
par excellence par définition puisse
armes égales sexy
pour la cuisson malheureusement le
tendance est finie donc on a vu la fin
des cuissards vraiment 2011 2012 on
vendait quand même quelques unes
aujourd'hui sa porte parce que c'est
dans les placards mais comme grande
produits dans les rayons chaussures
savard assez marginal dans l'avenir
comment progresser cuisse heures sans
faire trop moi je m'en sort très bien en
faisant du masculin féminin comme
toujours
donc en fait par exemple ce samedi
j'étais en crise armée je portais avec
une croûte pis d'une toxi dao féminine
donc j'avais mon taxi do et c'était le
blues blanc le toxedo et les cuissards
il n'y avait pas grand chose à dire donc
jeté très correct pour rendre les
cuisses à hambourg - sexe je conseille
vraiment le masculins féminines
mais allez-y donc allez-y pour des cuir
stretch une vrai talent assume et jouer
quel est votre conseil look pour la
cuissarde voilà comme je vous dis la
cuissarde c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'il faut vraiment savoir bien marier
parce que très vite ça tourne au
vulgaire donc vraiment une joue pas trop
course
et puis surtout des matières nobles
accueillir des choses assez sobre alors
petit récapitulatif des conseils d'une
professionnelle concernant la cuissarde
poser les tenues sobres pantalon ou
shorts aux jupes comme vous voulez mais
on dira jamais assez
plus la chaussure est imposante plus les
vêtements doivent être simples la
cuissarde plus souvent que vous ne le
pensiez
comme pour la botte que vous soyez
plutôt jupe strictes ou plutôt veste en
cuir
les cuissardes peuvent vous aider a
souligné un caractère bien trempé en
revanche évitez les talons trop hauts
c'est souvent eux qui viennent à
l'esprit lorsqu'on pense à une version
plutôt mal vue voire vulgaire de la
cuissarde la mini jupe et oui là non
plus vous ne pourrez pas lutter contre
les connotations le cuir tenté de
chaussée des matières plus nobles
lorsque la chaussure recouvre une partie
aussi conséquente du corps pour conclure
sur la cuissarde quel est le point
commun entre les cavaliers de la
renaissance et les héroïnes sexy des
années 70 la cuissarde naturellement
selon le cas le port de la cuissarde et
plus ou moins sensuelle je vous la corde
ce soulier fait partie des chaussures à
risque la cuissarde arrive au dessus du
genou et elle est ultra féminine mais la
cuissarde peut tout de même être porté
par toutes les femmes
il faut simplement choisir le modèle
plus épuré possible et choisir de belles
matières éviter impérativement le cuir
synthétique qui va briller et avoir un
rendu vulgaire à fuir également comme la
peste les talons aiguille choisissez
plutôt un talon et paix qui sera bien
plus chic
les valeurs sûres sont le cuir gras qui
n'accrochera pas le regard ou encore un
cuir velours dans les coloris à choisir
rester sobre noir ou marron
aucun autre coloris nette autorisés sauf
si vous souhaitez être condamnée par la
fashion police et pour les vêtements
associés aux cuissardes un collant
opaque gris foncé ou marron et une robe
en maille assez ample et bien sûr éviter
impérativement le décolleté
où tous les autres codes sexy à très
bientôt pour la suite d'histoires de
souliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]